bonsoir de 7,8 société ce soir nous nous
intéressons au label fait maison un
décret a été publié
il est entré en vigueur le 1er juillet
dernier ce label concerne les
établissements de restauration
commerciale ou de vente à emporter de
plats préparés
un nouveau label donc est ce utile ou
futile quel est son vrai qu'à cadrer
c'est la question que les questions que
je vais poser à mes invités ce soit en
plateau avec nous à sylvain van damme
est la vente de nam elle pardon bonsoir
et stan restaurateur à houdan vous êtes
membre de l'umih l'union des métiers et
de l'industrie et de l'industrie de
l'hôtellerie
j'en avais un bon soir vous êtes
restaurateur l encours est présent de la
confédération des professionnels
indépendants de l'hôtellerie en ile de
france
grégoire dynario pour soir vous êtes
restaurateur à montigny le bretonneux
labellisé maître restaurateur est
carrément de réponse aujourd'hui
commencer par vous même s'ils réclament
des platters finit par vous êtes
responsable de réseau soit 118 c'est un
groupement d'employeurs qui compte à ce
jour 70 adhérents alors avant de parler
de l'utilité pour les consommateurs de
ce label j'aimerais bien faire un point
justement sur ce label fait maison
cette mention je les dis s'applique aux
établissements de restauration
commerciale ou de vente à emporter de
plats préparés alors le label fait mais
on doit permettre de valoriser les plats
cuisinés entièrement sur place à partir
de produits bruts ou de produits
traditionnels de cuisine ça c'est ce que
dit le décret alors qu'est ce qu'un
produit brut
et bien selon le décret un produit brut
est un produit alimentaire n'ayant subi
aucune modification importante y compris
par chauffage marinage assemblage moi je
trouve que c'est un peu
vague première question j'ai envie de
vous poser un produit brut si je
comprends bien c'est pas un produit
frais c'est ça ce qu'il faut comprendre
dans ce décret vous avez bien pouvoir
regarder cet impôt du brut ce qui veut
dire que le grand débat sur le produit
surgelé ou congelés reste entier
cependant la grande problématique qui se
pose à notre métier depuis des années
c'est de savoir ce qui est fait maison
ce qui ne l'est pas alors je veux dire
c'est un débat qui dure depuis très
longtemps et un grand nombre
d'organisations professionnelles se sont
enterrés ce débat poussé par le
législateur qui voulait clarifier la
situation sur les cartes de restaurants
qui sont les vitrines des restaurants je
trouve que c'est pas trés clarifie passe
quand on dit produits bruts
voilà il faut aller chercher ce que ça
signifie alors que les gens pensent
produits frais mais c'est pas la même
chose demain non effectivement il y a
souvent confusion des genres et en plus
vous savez le produit tout frais tout
fait maison existe toujours dans
beaucoup de restaurants bien sûr mais il
ne compose pas 100% de la carte
il y a évidemment à la carte sont
d'autres produits qui sont bruts mais
qui ce pas obligatoirement des produits
qui sont issus du jardin le matin même
j'aurais continué à acheter un coup
d'oeil sur justement les définitions de
ceux de ce décret lors peuvent entrer
dans la composition d'un plat dit fait
maison les produits qui ont été
tranchées coupe et dépouillé moulu salle
et réfrigérer congelés surgelés alors
qu'en pensez vous et nord karak à
montréal et vous avez dit c'est énorme
c'est énorme parce qu'effectivement on
s'attend pas du tout avoir marqué déçu
des produits congelés surfinias où on
arrive
assez rapidement en fait à une confusion
déjà sur le sujet même du décret fait
maison
parce que si on sort un produit qui a
déjà été travaillé à l'extérieur de son
établissement et qui suffit d'y ajouter
quelques petites choses de le tout y est
pour que ce soit fait maison
ok mais dans ce cas est-ce qu'on n'a pas
déjà suffisamment de la belle qui est de
et d'organismes type les maîtres
cuisiniers les maîtres restaurateurs les
restaurants étoilés mais gastronomique
et semi gastronomique
enfin je veux dire est ce que dans tout
ça le consommateur on va faire une
différence parce que si c'est juste de
l'assemblage
c'est énorme à la pâte a triomphé de
l'assemblage et c'est du produit brut
saïb à avoir le label france les 10 vous
en pensez quoi de cette définition des
produits beauté des des produits
effectivement qu'on voit sur la
composition d'un plats faits maison peut
avoir du sens oui je la sers aussi mais
bon j'étais un peu déçu par la lecture
du décret je me suis aperçu que bon
finalement il avait amené cette nouvelle
appellation fait maison
qui devait arriver qu'il était prévu
mais cette appellation protège
maintenant dans le décret tous les
autres groupes de chaînes de façon de
fabriquer d'acheter congelés d'acheter
morcelé des produits bruts et qui ont
remis le débat à 0 qu'est ce que c'est
en réalité qui a fait maison
est ce que les restaurateurs maître
restaurateur restaurateurs de france qui
eux se targue d'acheter les produits
frais d'aller au marché les découper les
marines et les coupes et les cuirs et
les vendre avec leur passion est ce que
ces gens là ne sont pas pénalisés sur un
décret fait maison parce qu'on peut
toujours la sphère du fait d'un second
temps et les consommateurs comme moi et
qu'on entend fait maison
on se dit c'est fait comme à la maison
est ce que le gouvernement nous avons
des pros trompé sur son appellation
d'obligatoire aussi moi qui m'arrache
ont interpellé c'est obligatoire d'avoir
de notifier fait maison ou pas alors ça
c'est un problème
donc là on voit bien que la motivation
principale de toute cette histoire c'est
le renseigner le consommateur on voit
clair avec vous c'est plutôt louable oui
tout à fait louable sauf que là on voit
bien avec des professionnels on est là à
se poser des questions a essayé de
décortiquer le texte et on veut mettre
ce texte sous le nez des consommateurs à
ce qu'on a fait cercle à la confusion
est complète et totale alors qu'il
s'agit tout simplement de d'expliquer
aux consommateurs qu on achète des
produits qu on les cuisine qu'on leur
sert avec passion et amour de ce que
nous faisons donc c'est ça l'objectif
tout simple et ce texte probablement
qu'il va jeter le discrédit et il ya de
bonnes chances qu'ils servent pas à
grand chose sauf qu'en plus que moi je
regrette c'est que le caractère
obligatoire c'est à dire on va être
obligé d'indiquer certaines choses sur
nos cartes qui des obligations du
contrôle il faut contrôler si souligné
l'obligation est bien respectée qui dit
obligations du contrôle des inspecteurs
peut-être des sanctions voilà
tout ceci lit en double emploi avec le
titre de maître restaurateur qui
réunissait déjà comme ça oui
justement vous avez tous les deux le
label de maître restaurateur vous disiez
pourtant si l'on avait longtemps après
parlent entre eux mais c'était
indispensable d'avoir comme des labels
qui renseigne dise la vérité aux
consommateurs
oui mais qu'ils soient précis si la
belle que le consommateur sache à quoi
il correspond maîtres restaurateurs ont
quand j'ai obtenu le titre de most
orateurs j'étais obligé de l'expliquer
de les inscrire et à chaque audience de
leur expliquer lancer un label qui
existe depuis six ans qui est assez
compliquée parce qu'il ya pas mal de
compliments qui la commet piqué vous
trouver quelques mois on en dépendrait
des lettres il ya quand même pas mal de
choses à renseigner vous rentrez dans
les motrices et factures voilà en tout
cas c'est un peu ce que je suis en
utilisation produits frais ces
imposantes isation produit fera autour
de 80%
l'emploi de salariés qualifiés jean-luc
avec ce label fait maison
votre confédération demande est oui bien
sûr mélangez le tout et bien sûr
l'ensemble des professionnels le
demandaient depuis longtemps mais
effectivement il ya aussi à tenir compte
de la problématique économique
à l'intérieur le métier je voulais à
quelques chiffres c'est toujours
intéressant de le dire aux
téléspectateurs la restauration
commerciale en france et environ 120
mille entreprises sur 110 d'entreprise
80000 restaurateurs servent leurs
clients à table sur 80 milles
restaurateurs qui servent à leurs
clients à table 60000 propose de la
cuisine ethnique et 20000 d'avec les
usines françaises et sur 20000
restaurateurs qui sert de la cuisine
française
il y en a quatre mille qui s'enlise et
2300 je crois m'être un restaurateur
vous voyez un peu par conséquent que
veut le législateur et le législateur
finalement obéit à la demande du public
le public ce sont nos clients et qu'est
ce qu'ils demandent aux clients ils
demandent que dans les cartes des
restaurants
encore une fois les vitrines des
restaurateurs les choses soient dites
avec clarté et si possible avec le
maximum d'honnêteté en même temps est-ce
que les 20000 restaurateurs servant de
la cuisine française dans ce pays sont
capables tous de faire exclusivement des
produits frais faits maison non
clairement non donc le législateur a
prévu d'ouvrir la voie à d'autres types
de produits c'est la raison pour
laquelle il insiste sur les produits
bruts et ça fait toute une différence
par contre par contre il dit aussi quoi
il dit le restaurateur qui propose sur
sa carte des produits faits à
l'extérieur de son établissement par x
artisans ou entreprises de
l'agroalimentaire ne peut pas dire que
ces produits sont faits maison
or c'est vrai que pendant une période un
certain nombre de nos confrères ne
faisant pas très attention à la
situation commerciale dans laquelle ils
étaient ont été tentées de vendre à leur
carte souvent cher des produits qu'ils
ne fabriquait pas sans le dire
clairement
maintenant le législateur par ce décret
a décidé
que le restaurateur qui proposaient des
produits qui ne fabriquait pas lui même
ne pouvait pas porter une protection
c'est une protection maintenant
effectivement il ya un débat au sein
même de la profession en fonction des
catégories d'établissements vous avez
bien entendu 60000 restaurateurs
proposent de la cuisine ethnique
nous lisons pas ces problèmes-là 20000
de la cuisine française et dans les îles
françaises
vous avez le haut de gamme qui est doté
de des toiles au guide rouge ou de
reconnaissance dont les guides papier
vous avez bien sûr les maîtres
restaurateurs vous avez les
restaurateurs de france vous avez les
maîtres cuisiniers etc
il ya aussi le collège culinaire le
canadien devra alors c'est aujourd'hui
mardi 12 juillet vient de lancer son
premier collège culinaire d'île de
france à issy les moulineaux parfait ars
à cet in usa est très bien et d'ailleurs
la plupart des restaurateurs qui sont là
dedans cumule tout ça et c'est bien
voilà jusqu'où vous paraissent huile de
lamelles moi je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
trop là sûrement trop à nous notamment
autour des organisations
professionnelles de faire un peu le tri
mais vous allez monsieur du casque quand
il lançait son collègue claire le fond
si nous a pas demandé notre avis il l'a
fait voilà par contre le titre de maître
restaurateur lui est un titre décrété
lors de la négociation sur la batterie
pendant quatre ans par l'état savoir 80
points
mais tout ça finalement je crois va dans
le bon sens maintenant ce qu'il faut
bien sûr c'est tenir compte de la
réalité économique de nos restaurants or
cette réalité économique passe 1 par les
primes que nous devons pratiquer lorsque
nous avons des collaborateurs de haut
niveau qu'il faut payer c'est bien
normal d'ailleurs à qui il faut donner
des jours de congé avec lesquels il faut
avoir des relations sociales équilibré
ça coûte cher les produits frais quand
on parle des poissons bas il ya des
périodes contient pas de pêche ça a été
le cas cette année sur les périodes
pratiquement de mi novembre à mi janvier
dans une pêche aux canards après que la
belle maison et bien tout simplement
parce que là vous avez bien noté que
nous sommes dans les produits bruts ray
par conséquent beaucoup de restaurateurs
et sacs la normale préparer et de façon
tout à fait qualitatif des poissons
congelés qui sont des poissons qui sont
d'ailleurs souvent quand je vais sur les
bateaux dans des conditions non mais
attendez à rien n'est pas d'accord dans
les questions et parler de ta feront pas
la question
j'aime aller à qui vous avez évidemment
un équilibre économique est beaucoup
plus sont obligés de tenir comme ça
alors en scène marion déséquilibres
économiques il faut trouver du coup on
peut parler mon président mais bon
l'ensemble des chiffres sur la partie du
poisson on a manqué de poisson à cause
des tempêtes et du mauvais temps c'est
vrai il y avait beaucoup moins de pêche
sur les côtes françaises
or il ya du poisson d'élevage
d'excellente qualité par exemple moi je
me fournis à une pisciculture artisanal
tout près d'ici 20 à 80 km qui fait un
très beau travail bio donc il ya ça et
ensuite il ya le poisson qui vient aussi
par avion et des poissons qui vient de
mériter leur indicible
c'est plus difficile je vais pas
demander d'ailleurs comment vous
cuisinez vous en différence entre
produits frais produits bruts en
pourceaux ses passions pourcentage on
peut le dire
chez moi c'est 100% prince est ce un pur
sang frais voyez là on est enfin on
n'est plus en train de parler de brut là
on en train de parler de frais c'est
comme tu as deux femmes apparaissent
aussi sa maison qui qui qui qu'on
n'entende pas dans le fait maison
on parle pas de produits frais au
parlement environ 12 euros et moi je
trouve ça dommage parce qu'en fait
conclusion mais nous mais c'est très
bien parce que je trouve que c'est la
même pour les consommateurs quand ils
ont sept ce décret devant les yeux parce
que concrètement un établissement qui va
être par exemple à 100% sur du produit
frais placé à côté d'un établissement
qui va faire du fait maison avec ce
décret il va y avoir une différence de
prix à la carte quand même parce qu'un
produit dérivé les biographies chiens
ont les mêmes brûleront les mêmes et
poteau le consommateur donc un moment il
va dire parmi mes laisse un maître
cuisinier oui mais là il marqué ces
faits maison oui bah c'est 30 euros de
moins qu'en valeur alors est ce que
c'est vraiment un intérêt
attention c'est pas une nouvelle chose
hein ce ce décret et on est tous on
n'est pas contre mais je dis juste que
ça manque de
émotion voilà pour le consommateur fait
peut-être celle un peu trop large ça
divise par exemple fourni ces frais
produits nous on est grands moments sur
des produits frais mais on travaille
aussi des produits surgelés bien entendu
et le client le sait parfaitement chez
nous sauf que deux marques pas comme on
fait en italie les produits je lis la
rade l on sait réellement sur les
caméras et la glace dans les clubs
italiens non j'aime dans le
professionnel on m'avait demandé tous
ouais parce que en plus très honnêtement
on le voit d'ailleurs dans la presse
grand public de plus en plus on des
douanes cette situation là et c'est une
bonne chose on a évolué c'est vrai que
les produits surgelés
il ya vingt ans c'était vraiment pas bon
il se trouve que les progrès qui ont été
faits dans ce domaine font que beaucoup
de produits sont d'excellente qualité
mais encore une fois ce qui moi ma porte
c'est pas le devenir de d
de 3000 disons 4000 restaurateurs qui
font du haut de gamme
notre position à nous confédération
professeurs des indépendants cpih
c'est aussi de défendre l'intérêt de
tous les restaurateurs qui sont
adhérents chez nous et y en a beaucoup
qui aujourd'hui sur le plan économique
était ennuyé et bien la maintenance est
ce décret va leur permettre d'avoir une
vie un peu facilité et en tout cas de ne
plus être tentés de mentir c'est une
bonne source de trouve tout à fait avant
de cogner cette discussion et notamment
par et des contrôles vous avez abordé la
question des contrôles et c'est vrai que
ça sera intéressant parce que si je
comprends bien tout le monde pourra
mettre le label fait-maison n'y a pas
forcément de vérification si je suis
j'espère qu'il y en aura une demi-heure
à dix bordeaux on te met ça serait à
quelle fréquence et elky pour les faire
alors avant justement de parler des
problèmes des contrôles ou propose
d'écouter les saint quentinois les
consommateurs saint quentinois nous
sommes allons alors demandé ce qu'il
pensait justement de ces labels fait
maison voici leurs réponses au micro de
patrick jacques de dixmude
je trouve que c'est très bien parce que
manger du surgelé on peut les manger
chez soi les surgelés
voilà après sur l'idée pourquoi pas
après prévoir au niveau des prix est-ce
que ça reste
des prix abordables mais sur l'idée à
les produits maison
moi je trouve ça bien au label de plus
encore
mais bon si c'est fait correctement
pourquoi pas ce serait plutôt bien parce
que beaucoup effectivement il ya
beaucoup de brasserie qui disent que
c'est fait maison et on sait très bien
que c'est acheter à métro et aura vu
juste de la crème chantilly et autres
c'est pas tant bon c'est plutôt bien ça
permet d'être sûr de ce qu'on mange et
on voit un peu partout du fait maison
n'a jamais trop confiance donc c'est un
vrai label ça me semble plutôt pas mal
de savoir ce qu'on mange faut pas marqué
fait-maison faut marquer puis à la
maison c'est pas pareil
il a raison ce monsieur à la fin
effectivement c'est non enfin je n'ai
pas dit que vous n'êtes pas d'accord on
fait bluffer maison qu'est ce que ça
allait je trouve qu'un consommateur
interviewés étaient quand même je suis
clairvoyant sur qui ne seraient pas
d'accord avec eux évidemment simplement
le fait maison est clairement indiqué
dans le texte c'est cuisine à la maison
après la problématique qui se pose dans
notre métier à travers le panel les
restaurateurs ils sont nombreux ces bons
surgelés ou pas hachez trancher et c'est
bon l'essentiel c'est quoi finalement
c'est bien de dire au client que ce
qu'ils ont dans leur assiette a été
cuisiné alors par exemple le cas de
cette personne qui dit dans le micro
trottoir finalement on prend un plat
cuisiné on rajoute de la crème fraîche
ou 2 3 brins de persil est ce que ça
c'est du fait maison n'ont non seulement
pas fallait pas non sur les pas de ces
clairement indiqué dans le décret la
commande dans le décret c'est clairement
indiqué dans le décret auparavant on
avait encore les restaurateurs avaient
la possibilité d'en billets clarifier
s'est améliorée mais ça a relancé un
débat parce que
la provenance des produits n'est pas
marqué la façon dont il a été conservé
la façon dont il tranché par qui on
intervient pas non plus sûres j'en ai
acheté la moitié du tout fait et je les
transforme et à la maison sur quels
produits je me sais du fait maison c'est
pas du fait maison
les proportions est ce que toute ma
carte est fait maison
c'est alors que j'ai acheté lizard hui
ça l'industriel annonce une
problématique s'il vient c'est
dramatique c'est est ce que nos cartes
doivent de doivent devenir des lexiques
juridique abandonner la notion d'abord
là pour faire un peu rêver
qu'est ce que demande le client que tu
as chez toi que krikor hachoir confusion
chez moi mieux que ça la cagnotte de ça
ils demandent à voir un cadre plutôt
sympathique et confortable ils demandent
à être bien accueillie et agréable ça
servait à stocker et il demande est il
demande à bien manger bon mais ces trois
paramètres particuliers ont un peu
changé d'ordre il fut une longue période
que nous avons connues puisque nous
sommes à peu près de la même génération
où c'était d'abord la nourriture
maintenant le cadre le confort la
qualité de l'accueil et du service ont
aussi un cerveau est d'accord là-dessus
sourire bonjour c'est essentiel ouais
une enquête est faite pour lui
ce sujet là la qualité de la nourriture
n'est plus le problème première
problématique du client
là on est bien reçu même si c'est pas du
fait maison mais que ça ils seront
gustativement et qu'on aura le rapport
qu'elle enverra rien leur solde il sert
à rien mesures il a écrit il a été alors
je crois jour à savoir j'aurais revenir
sur la question du pouvoir et punir les
tricheurs apport punir les tricheurs
en tout cas les signaler que moi en tout
cas j'aurai revenir sur cette question
des contrôles comment ça va se passer
demain sur vos cartes vous avez pas moi
c est ce que c'est vous qui décrétait je
vais mettre le petit logo alors qu'il
est encore le fameux petit logo fait
maison j'ai passé sera une petite
casserole ou quoi
nous sommes dispensés de préciser ça le
titre de maître restaurateur est la
plaque maître restaurateur son existence
d'avoir indiqué en face de chaque plat
fait mais au paf le maison tranché à la
maison malgré que votre label maître
restaurateur il est bien connu et bien
qu'à parce que moi quand j'entends la
belle fait maison je sais ce que ça veut
dire
label maître restaurateur et justement
l'ombre on peut enfin alors ce qui me
concerne je regrette beaucoup que au
lieu de promouvoir ce titre qui existe
déjà et il faut rappeler aussi qu'il
faut rappeler aussi c'est important que
c'est le seul label officiel d'état en a
qu'un c'est le titre de maître
restaurateur plus de temps et plus de
publicité à faire valoir les labels qui
existe déjà et sans que ça entache le
petit restaurateur parce que la cuisine
française c'était ça l'objectif du
décret c'est de faire valoir la cuisine
française
on a déjà des labels existants que les
gens nouvelle génération ne prête pas
particulièrement attention ou ne
connaissent même pas on aurait pu mettre
de l'argent pour promouvoir ces labels
là pour les mettre en évidence
et puis à côté ok dire qu'un petit
restaurateur qui ne travaillent pas que
le produit frais a aussi une qualité
mais il va se démarquer tout seul aussi
parce que c'est bon c'est paradoxal dans
ce label cboe finalement vous en êtes
dispensé parce que vous avez un titre de
maître restaurateur qui supérieur à
dispenser de l'obligation de faire du
frère m'a vraiment d'accord 80 pour
sandra de produits frais je rappelle
pour ce label maître restaurateur qui
existe depuis depuis six ans mais vous
êtes dispensé de mettre ce fameux logo
fait maison donc en fait pour les gens
vont venir chez vous on dire bah rien
est fait maison parce que vous avez pas
le logo c'est un comble c'est vraiment
un sens c'est un peu extrêmement dommage
mais en même temps vous avez raison sur
le fait que nous avons mal communiquer
sur le sujet vous et moi vous n'êtes pas
m resteront non je suis pas maître
restaurateur
mais on a mal communal
pour une raison simple c'est que lorsque
le titre a été conçue c'était dans le
cadre de la négociation sur la baisse du
taux de tva
malheureusement et là il faut s'en
prendre à nous les organisations
professionnelles l'umih ou la cph lui
défend plutôt les grandes boîtes ou
plutôt les indépendants a mal communiqué
sur le sujet il y avait une obligation
de baisse des prix elle a été fait dans
les maisons comme les nôtres nous avons
baissé les prix c'est clair mais les
médias eux ont considéré que ce n'était
pas suffisant
mais une fois les médias qui décide les
baisses de prix sont suffisantes aux
parieurs sont le relais at il expliqué
je pense d'ailleurs qu'on leur a mal
expliqué ensuite on a là deux
responsables de tous étaient venus en
nombre de jours n'est pas responsable je
dis seulement que les médias ont évoqué
autre chose que le fait que nous avions
baissé les prix or nous l'avons fait
pour je crois pas sur les gratte-ciel de
karkh voilà 80 % des professionnels ont
joué le jeu
ensuite il y avait une obligation
d'investissement beaucoup investie puis
avait évidemment les obligations
sociales aux jouets tout le personnel
bénéficie de la mutuelle tout le
personnel bénéficie d'un recadrage des
relations sociales entre le restaurateur
est le cri la paix et la prime tva est à
neutre
voilà dont les anime dont les types
d'ordinateurs est venue de là il a été
finalement mal mis en scène dommage je
suis le premier à regretter
du coup bah c'est vrai qu'un certain
nombre de restaurateurs dont moi
d'ailleurs se sont découragés et ont dit
bon bah si c est vous par exemple sur
votre carte vous aurez qu on savait déjà
que mais vous aurez de qu'ils auront
fait maison
jean dujardin 100 % sont plus clairement
son fils mais en même temps ça va
inciter tous les restaurateurs y compris
les restaurateurs d'y entrer mais bon
marché de faire plus attention
et quand même la parution de ce décret
encore une fois tire vers le haut
l'ensemble de la profession et ça c'est
une très bonne chose
c'est une bonne chose je voulais quand
même sur les contrôles est ce qu'il y
aura des contrôles de ce label ou pas
oui bien sûr
mais alors que là pour la location d'une
à belz et collectivités publiques et à
l'état pour nous contrôler et seine nord
europe pour mettre ce label c'est à la
bonne volonté du restaurateur c'est
obligatoire c'est le restaurateur qui
décident sur sa carte
vous mettez 100% de la belle fait maison
bien besoin de signes apparaissent mal à
faire s'il ne veut pas le faire il n'est
pas obligé et enfin à l'attention de
ceux qui m'entourent
moi ce qui m'intéresse ce qui ce qui
m'interpelle un petit peu c'est ok le
contrôle mais à quelle fréquence ont par
qui quand comment
quelles sanctions voilà parce que on a
aussi un moment donné c'est quoi le
travail épuisant du mal à contrôler et
donc contrôler control contrôle
enfin on peut par perdants se tirer des
balles dans le pied non plus donc je
veux dire que les professionnels à
travers leurs responsabilités les
responsables syndicaux dont je fais
parti dont il est parti donc les coiffes
une sortie aussi nous avons travaillé
sur ce décret nous avons essayé de faire
en sorte qu'il soit un bon moyen de
tirer vers le haut l'ensemble d'une
profession je crois que nous nous y
parviendrons
il en faut pour essayer de voir à
l'antenne pour résumer c'est plutôt bien
aux labels totalement sa recadrer un
débat ça disons amené disons plein
d'autres nouvelles idées qui va falloir
canaliser c'est vrai on va vers une
démarche qualitative de plus en plus
contrôlée par l'état un pour dix ont
limité tous les débordements des petites
interventions les concernés c'est ça qui
est important donc à nous un nouveau
label dans la restauration la belle fait
maison n'oublie pas les autres labels
notamment celui de m restera un peu
oublié merci en tout cas vous 4 d'être
venu sur le plateau du 7-8 société
c'était la dernière émission de la
saison
pour ma part je vous donne rendez vous
le mardi 2 septembre pour une nouvelle
la saison merci aux équipes de la
rédaction et ou du montage qui ont
permis à cette édition et puis les
précédentes bel été à vous